it's not long now until destiny rise of
iron releases and bungee have spilt the
beans to Game Informer about what
guardians can expect when they venture
into the latest expansion it was already
known that rise of Ironwood introduced a
new social space called fell winter peak
however there may be more to it than we
thought players will need to take back
the area from the expansions new fall
and devil splicer enemies in order to
unlock new gear vendors and bounties
creative lead Christopher Barrett has
also teased that the new space may also
hide some secrets killing game informer
there's this whole portion of fur winter
peak that is normally locked except
during special events there may be some
secret ways to get back there in
addition to the phone when to pick
social space Bungie is adding the
plaguelands a new explorable zone that
will appear near the Cosmodrome on earth
inside you complete the five new story
missions that will tell the story of the
iron Lords and Lord Saladin while not
lengthy the story missions will feature
cinematics that explore the background
of the iron Lords and just like in the
taken king once you've burned through
the story content you'll unlock
additional missions and quests the new
enemies that you'll do battle with in
rise of iron are the devil splices
mutated forms of the Fallen around a
century before the events of destiny a
golden age' nanotechnology called Siva
close to serious threat to humanity the
iron Lords sacrificed themselves in
order to contain the threat by sealing
it behind the walls of the plaguelands
somehow the Fallen have found their way
inside and are using Seaver to augment
themselves and grow more powerful the
new enemies will fight with tweaked
abilities like a berserk ability for
vandals when they're on low health and
will feature new aesthetics that will
set them apart from the existing form
kind of like to take in PvE players will
also have a new co-op arena to tackle in
rise of iron archons forge will feature
rounds that are shorter than prison of
elders but more robust than Court of
Oryx the arena will unlock at the
completion of the campaign missions and
is triggered by using siva offerings
much like the runes required for court
of Oryx rounds in archons forge end with
a boss that drops exclusive gear Bungie
have emphasized the collaborative nature
of this mode as it allows your fire team
to work together with other random
players speaking of gear buns your
overhauling the way artifacts work rise
of iron will introduce eight new
artifacts that can be equipped by any
class each artifact is tied to one of
the iron Lords and will carry unique
abilities for example one particular
artifact will allow you to briefly gain
an enemy's allegiance by punching them
in the face while another will add the
ability to deflect energy-based
projectiles with swords you may remember
a guardian wielding a flaming acts in
the rise of iron announcement trailer
this weapon is actually a relic you come
across during your time in the new
expansion the flaming axe reach I
mo when doing light attacks and expense
mo faster when doing heavy attacks if
you can keep the ammo above a certain
level however the relic will deal double
damage as with all destiny expansions
the light level cap will be increased
this time to 385 with all gear from the
taken King onwards being scaled to match
the cap will be raised to 400 a few
weeks after launch to coincide with the
release of the hard mode rise of iron
raid there are also new cosmetic items
which are basically skins you can apply
to weapons and armor Bungie have also
confirmed that the Halloween celebration
festival of the Lost and sparrow racing
league timed events will be coming back
to destiny after rise of iron launches
rise of iron is the fourth expansion to
hit destiny since its launch in 2014 it
will be the first expansion to release
for current-gen consoles only and will
be available on sep tember 20th for all
the info on rise of iron and everything
swords and magic in space keep your
sights on gamespot